If you want to know how Tim Curry’s Pennywise
from the 1990 TV mini-series IT is hidden
in this trailer, then stick around to the
end of this video.
The trailer opens with an overhead shot of
the town.
This same angle is also seen in 1989 during
the first movie.
Here are the two side by side for comparison.
We then see the missing posters that are piling
up once again.
The town is decorated with balloons in the
background, possibly for the Derry Canal Days
festival, which the carnival and celebration
where It makes a return in the book.
We can’t see the movie theater marquee,
but in the first movie, the titles were accurate
to the time period, so maybe in this movie
it’ll be showing 10 Cloverfield Lane, Don’t
Breathe, Lights Out…
UGH WHAT A GOOD YEAR.
In the next scene we see someone drowning
in the sewers.
The first time he comes up from the water
he sees nothing.
The second time there’s blood in the water,
and the third time there’s a good old friend
who just woke up from his nappy nap and probably
wants to play.
Jade of the Orient is the same Chinese restaurant
that the Losers Club has their reunion lunch
at in the book.
You see the words “try me” on this drink
of the month advertisement.
Is this a coincidence or is this Pennywise
saying “try me”.
Challenge me and see what happens.
In the book, Pennywise does manipulate the
dishes served at the lunch, and leaves similar
messages throughout the novel, so I think
it’s a possibility.
This shot of Beverly is brief, but you’ll
notice the tall buildings, rain, a police
car and the fact that she’s not wearing
makeup as she does in her other appearances.
I think this is her late night escape from
her abusive husband Tom Rogan.
The two live together in Chicago at the start
of Chapter 2 and Beverly didn’t have much
time to grab anything as she escaped.
Everyone is rushing to get inside, but she’s
focused on getting away from her abusive husband.
Like I mentioned earlier, I think this carnival
is part of the Derry Canal Days Festival,
and one room in the funhouse contains a series
of swinging clown pendulums.
Some of these look just like Tim Curry’s
Pennywise from the 1990 adaptation of IT,
it has the yellow clown suit, orange pom-pom
buttons and red tufts of hair, there’s a
similar reference in the first movie where
Curry’s Pennywise can be seen in the room
full of clown statues.
This funhouse scene isn’t in the book, but
there is a scene where Bill encounters a kid
on a skateboard and Bill warns him not to
play around the sewers.
Then Bill gets this urge to ride the skateboard
because the inner child inside of him is essentially
re-emerging.
So I think instead of the skateboard, Bill
relives his childhood by going into the funhouse
maze and instead of him warning the kid, he
maybe saves the kid while he’s is in actual
danger.
Also, can I just point out this is the second
horror movie this year to have a mirror maze?
"WHAT IF I'M A MONST--"
"ASKJFLSDFJKL"
Bill crashes into this glass that seems to
be right in front of him.
Does It maybe have the ability to change the
layout of the maze to drive Bill crazy?
If so, it could make for some great psychological
horror.
When Pennywise is revealed, the tongue is
hanging out further than we’ve ever seen
it, like some kind of weird smartphone filter.
I think this is to show that IT is preparing
for a meal because it senses fear, and feeds
off of fear.
"I'll take all of you...
I'll feast on your flesh as I feed on your
fear..."
We saw this a lot with all the drool in the
first movie, and I think this tongue shot
is essentially taking that to the next level.
When the Losers show up at the house on 29
Neibolt St, Eddie has a bloody gauze on his cheek
similar to where Beverly has one as a kid;
Mike seems to have wrap around his wrist,
maybe a second coming of Eddie having the
cast in the first one, and Bill is missing
from the group.
Maybe he tries going in by himself and the
others have to come save him?
In this next scene, a red balloon floats by
this facility and seems to drive the inmates
crazy.
This guy has the initials J.H.P.H on his back.
The facility that Henry Bowers is kept in
during the 27 year gap in the book is called
Juniper Hill Mental Asylum, so I think for
the movie it’s been renamed to Juniper Hill
Psychiatric Hospital.
Maybe Henry isn’t the only mental case that
It gets on It’s side side this time.
Also, these guys look like they’re at a
metal concert.
"IT's coming back around every 27 years!"
These are the same three doors the Losers
Club encounters inside 29 Neibolt Street in
the first movie, but one cool detail I noticed
is that the blood is trickling up rather than
down, just as Pennywise is rising again, or
perhaps “floating” back to the surface.
Now in the book there’s a chapter called
Walking Tours where the Losers go back to
revisit locations that were important to them
in their childhood.
Richie goes back to City Center where he first
encountered It, Beverly goes to where her
parents’ house was, and Bill goes downtown.
Maybe in the movie though, Bill goes back
to his childhome home as well.
In this shot we what looks to be some kind
of dream or hallucination with Child Bill
and Adult Bill side by side in the flooded
basement.
Either that, or this is some kind of 27 year
challenge on social media.
In the first trailer, there’s a shot of
someone splashing around in blood, and in
this one, we see that it’s actually Beverly
revisiting the old elementary school bathroom
where she was bullied as a child.
The graffiti “H*TE CLOWN” has been crossed
out, but it’s unclear what it says under
that.
Other graffiti includes Greta Keane is a B*tch.
Greta Keane is the movie reimagining of a
character named Greta Bowie from the book
-- in the movie she’s also the daughter
of Norbert Keane, the pharmacist who tries
to warn Eddie that his aspirator is a gazebo.
"You know what these are?
They're gazebos!!
They're bull***t!!"
This small text right here says Beverly Marsh
gets around -- which references the rumor
spread by Greta and her friends that Beverly
is this big sl*t.
Stop censoring me YouTube godd***it!
There’s also a good look at the bruising
on Beverly’s arm where her husband most
likely grabbed her during her escape.
Here’s another quick Pennywise appearance
in what I’d assume is Beverly trying to
break them out of 29 Neibolt Street.
And then if you pause near the end of the
trailer, you’ll get the only look we have
so far at one of the other forms of It, it
looks like some kind of Zombie-like creature
that can swim.
Can’t wait to see what that is, maybe it’s
like an undead version of Bev’s father.
Here we have one somebody falling down the
well and into this light.
The true form of It is something called The
Deadlights, which are teased at a couple of
times.
Maybe what we’re seeing here is similar
to what happened to Henry Bowers when he was
pushed into the well by Mike.
For more on that, watch my full video on my
three theories for It: Chapter 2.
Or maybe this is Bill or Richie entering the
Macroverse -- I won’t put any spoilers in
this video, but fans of the book will know
what I’m talking about.
One of our last shots Pennywise shutting this
door back up to the surface.
The only thing this reminds me of is this
one scene from the mini-series that isn’t
in
the book.
"Take your pick.
B-b-b-billy boy!"
Be sure to let me know what else you noticed
in the trailer, and click the video on the
left to see my analysis on the other trailer
for It Chapter 2.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld, I’ve
got a load of content planned leading up to
the next movie, and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.